the taliban's route of afghanistan took
afghans by surprise every bit as much as
the watching world outside
but descent is now starting to emerge
this is the city of jalalabad in the
east of the country
protesters took down the white taliban
flag raised over the weekend and
replaced it with the afghan tricolor
they are defined but for now outnumbered
i'm standing here in front of you you
can hit me with 30 bullets kill me
i will sacrifice my life for this flag
this is my flag my government will soon
be back god willing
after 20 years in exile one of the
taliban's co-founders muller baradar has
returned to afghanistan
he spent years in a pakistan prison but
he is now back and will probably be one
of the senior figures in the new
administration
most of the old government has fled
today the uae confirmed that ousted
president ashraf ghani has been given
sanctuary in the emirates
according to one diplomat he escaped
with 169 million dollars when kabul was
falling around him
despite fighting the taliban for 20
years britain's military chief says the
uk's enemy for two long decades must now
be given a chance
let's see how this evolves because it
may well be that we're surprised by it
yes we should do it very carefully yes
we should be fundamentally suspicious
because of course we know where they
came from and we've also seen behavior
by different elements of the taliban
which we absolutely wouldn't condone and
indeed it has been brutal in many ways
in other parts of afghanistan but we
should give them the space at the moment
to demonstrate whether or not they're
going to govern differently
but there are already signs of the old
taliban this man had his face blackened
and was tied up and paraded in kabul
he's been accused of theft
there are also reports of whippings and
violence being meted out elsewhere in
the country
there are reports of protests in other
cities too the taliban it seems might
have swept to power relatively
unchallenged but the protests might also
just now be starting
alastair uncle sky news